well today is giving tuesday this is a
campaign that
was born in new york eight years ago to
encourage people to give back and do
good
local organizations are in need and
putting out the call for help
bianca holman is live with more good
morning bianca
hey good morning sherry you know when
our neighbors are in need
they are always there these groups these
nonprofit groups like hearts alive here
that helps our furry friends
but now these same groups that help us
day in and day out they need our help
today is giving tuesday and it's an
opportunity for you to
give back to a cause that you believe in
maybe it's your alma mater maybe it's a
faith-based group or a health foundation
that has impacted your family
like diabetes or cancer this has been a
rough year for everyone even groups that
look out for our furry friends
hearts alive village is a community
support group that looks to keep pets in
their original home and find forever
homes and forever families for pets that
might have been abused or neglected
sheryl green from hearts alive village
tells us that they've gone from serving
3000 families with
free pet food to 5-thousand green says
they have a goal of 50 thousand dollars
to help ensure the warehouse stays
stocked
and that they can heal animals that come
to their new low cost vet clinic that's
opening next week
now is the perfect time to really donate
in someone's name
rather than buying that you know cheapy
little gift
just to say i'm thinking about you why
not do something that
they care about you know so many people
love animals
and what a wonderful gift to see that
animals have been saved and have been
helped in your name
and of course hearts alive villa is just
one organization here's a few
other organizations participating in
giving tuesday safeness they help those
escaping from domestic violence
situation
situations nevada partnerships for
homeless youth and
many are familiar with catholic
charities three square and red cross but
again these are just
a few across the valley that are
participating again if there's a cause
that you're interested in
go to their website and you can donate
and also green says that if you can't
give money
check with the organization to see if
that if they're taking volunteers some
essential groups are taking volunteers
or if they have items that you can
donate for example you can bring pet
food here
at hearts of life village or if other
groups are collecting non-perishable
items reporting live from near rainbow
in charleston bianca holman
8 news now bianca thank you very much it
is now 5